[Music]
feel like I've seen I know so many of
your recent guests who just have on but
there's a lot there's so many that I see
your feet and like oh no them know them
well that's great you have I had I mean
had Louis recently right Louis while ago
Rob Bell yeah Rob love Rob I just did
his podcast oh you did yeah he's a he's
a well member you know yeah I I didn't
know that he was at the gala and I
missed him yeah there and it wasn't
until we got back and I was like wait
you were there this year
stop Cortina which I think you know
right we got shame ice cream so you have
to keep jumping the shark with this
thing this might be my last my last year
of knowing what to do
but that is me serene so it's a foot
whoa it's in the round the whole thing's
gonna be a big circle this is the first
San Francisco right find an uncle and
then all the content is shot
specifically in 360 just for the gala
so I'm doing a three-hour screening
tonight of all the contents whoa but it
should be really so much for the venue
it's the armory it's a forty thousand
yeah I got the invite I'm gonna come
with you talk again yeah I think we're
gonna do it
that'd be fun so cool pop-up and tell
you this was actually the this wasn't
ours was it we sent an hourglass out as
the invite to all members
oh cool was it the whole gamut concepts
called the gift of time uh-huh where
were always like next level with like
the marketing stuff man
well we're gonna track the so we're
gonna I'll let you in so little bit in
the insight wool we're gonna fund crowd
fund a drilling rig for $700,000 in the
room we're gonna put everybody's names
on it
that donates anything call it a hundred
bucks and then I'm gonna put up a
calendar of the next four years and say
great we have a rig now let's run it
into the future so every years a million
bucks so we're gonna sell units of time
uh-huh I'm gonna sell a drilling day a
drilling our a drilling day three
drilling days which is a well a drilling
week a drilling
month and as you buy time we're just
gonna see this calendar you know start
filling out right and what we're also
gonna do is we're gonna we're actually
quantifying the amount of time that
you'll be saving women it says you bite
about a wall that's turning into
multiple because we've got the data now
we've been interviewing in these
villages it's a completely different way
of thinking about the impact mm-hmm
right yeah not just dirty waters because
I'm clean but the time that women are
saving what would you do with millions
of hours right the whole gender aspect
of the work that you do I think is
something that that that people don't
realize until they become educated the
impact that the water has on education
and female empowerment yeah it's it's
real women and girls really women and
girls only when it comes to water right
because break that down a little bit I
mean basically traditionally the women
are responsible for collecting the water
and this involves hours and hours and
hours of walking each way to a well
that's it well it's not even well that's
the problem it's a it's a pond it's a
river it's often brown viscous dirty
water
mm-hm and you know the their their risk
of animal attacks you know we hear
stories of women getting attacked by
hyenas they're at risk of rape you know
as they're far away from home if you're
a woman you're giving birth you've got
to give birth away from home at the
waterhole so you're effectively camping
out because you need the water uh-huh
and you know so not only you know when
we're able to bring clean drinking water
into a village not only are we
eliminating that walk therefore
reclaiming you know all these these
hours every day imagine getting five
hours back in your day every day seven
days a week
so it's yeah the downstream impact of
that can't even be measured because it
translates into education and job you
know working and being productive in
other ways yeah it's it's incredible
there was a UN report that that was
released they tracked the economic
impact of water so you know we've said
we know water makes people healthier
fifty-two percent of the disease
throughout the developing world or what
some people would call the third-world
is actually because of bad water and a
lack of sanitation but the UN wanted to
see you know what about the economics
behind this so they found every dollar
that you invested in clean water and
sanitation yielded a four to eight
dollar return Wow so why are made people
wealthier and it was it was money not
spent on medicine so if you're not sick
you're not headed to the clinic I
remember one of the things that used to
surprise me was learning the the
impediment for so many of these people
is actually getting to the clinic when
they get there the drugs are often
affordable and subsidized but the taxi
to the clinic could be a month's wages
so you don't have it so your kid dies in
the village of diarrhea something
completely preventable so I just I love
the idea that by bringing clean drinking
water and sanitation into villages
you're actually making you're improving
the local economy you're you're
measurably lifting people out of extreme
poverty yeah it solves a battery of
problems at the source speaking of the
source the last time we I guess we got
together it was probably a year and a
half ago and that was right on the eve
of you launching the spring yep and in
that this past year and a half he was so
helpful gone on to become super
successful and during that period of
time you wrote this book that just came
out there so congratulations on that I
think super exciting thanks for having
me back here I'm about I'm about I don't
know 50 or 60 pages into it I'm right at
the part where you hook up with that DJ
that you used to employ various not yet
across yeah who had found faith in a
certain respect and that guy kind of
becomes your he becomes like this not
mentor but kind of like he ushered you
into a new way of thinking about who you
are and what yeah yeah like a pivotal
character yeah there are a couple really
important guides or mentors I would have
said at that time he was a he was a
mentor even though it was a brief brief
time of counseling that really moved
in the right direction yeah it's funny
dr. Gary who you'll you'll meet later in
the book it becomes really my first
guide when I go to Liberia in Africa and
you know his his story was so amazing he
had he was a surgeon from California
from this area actually and he had heard
that there was this hospital ship that
surgeons could join and they could
operate for free on people without
access to medical care and he signs up
for three months all right I can I can
leave my practice behind for three
months and when I volunteered and set
foot on the ship he'd been there 21
years Wow
they never left he's still there Wow
he's in year 34 or 35 so there's a bunch
of these characters you know throughout
the book that just confirmed to me that
I'm on the right path that this is a
life worth living you know a life of
service imagine giving three-and-a-half
decades he just never went back to his
practice I mean I went back to making
money and and you know buying the the
cars and doing all the things been told
since youth are there marxism success
recipe of not only success but but being
happy and and living a fulfilled life
which we know intellectually is not the
case and yet it it's so difficult for us
to wrap our heads around a different way
of living and I think of all the people
that I've met you are not just a shining
example of the power of service to
transform LA I mean you might be the
best example of anyone I've ever met of
somebody who weathered a dark night of
the soul and then was able to channel
that experience into not only changing
your own life but having this monumental
impact on millions of people across the
world like I was thinking like do I know
anyone else who's had a more profound
impact on the planet than you and the
work that you do and I don't think that
I I don't think that I have I don't
think I don't think I do I mean it's
really remarkable and when you were last
year
we tracked your whole story and I don't
want to spend too much time on that
because people can go and listen to that
episode we do it when it was
like two hours but the show has grown
quite a bit and not everyone's gonna go
back and listen to that so I think it is
worth kind of recapping you know some of
the highlights there contextualise what
we're talking about sure um you know I
think my my sister see you get a little
different perspective too when you write
a book when you spend two years you know
and write one hundred fifty thousand
words which became we start to
understand your story in a different way
oh wait I forgot that thing hat was
really important and you find the
threads that connect everything so I
think you know my story was three acts
there was Act one which was growing up
in a very conservative Christian home my
mom became an invalid when I was four
after a carbon dioxide gas leak in our
home and this was a shock to our family
she almost dies a faulty heat exchanger
had caused the the problem and I I'm
instantly thrust into a caregiver role
as a four year old and I take care of
mom I'm doing the cooking and doing the
cleaning I play piano every Sunday in
church
I don't cuss I don't drink I don't sleep
around I don't smoke so that's act 1 act
218 happens I discovered New York City I
it's it's it's actually probably most
most close to the parable of the
prodigal son where I just flip everybody
the bird flip my parents the bird I
flipped the you know the church the
burden say now it's my turn okay I
played by the rules now I'm gonna
explore the other side and I moved to
New York City I felt like well if you
want to rebell in style I heard that
there was this job called a nightclub
promoter where you can get paid to drink
alcohol professionally so the thought of
being a professional drinker
was that was appealing and you know at
18 years old three three years before
I'm even allowed to be inside nightclubs
I just start climbing up the social
ladder of New York I want to be the king
of New York I want to be the guy
spraying the champagne over the crowd
from the top of the mezzanine to the DJ
booth and work at 40 different
nightclubs over in the next ten years so
18 to 28 is kind of a blur
start with smoking then drinking then
drugs then the gambling then the
pornography then the strip clubs then
this just kind of descent into hedonism
and debauchery and degeneracy yeah and
and I'm gonna interject from time to
time but apologies for that but what I
realized like I knew it was I knew
you're a baller nightclub owner and I
knew your party and pretty hard but from
the book was was you know as somebody
you know who's explored that terrain
myself it was it was darker than I
suspected and you were you were deeper
in that hole then then I thought like
you you tend to kind of you tell your
story a lot and and you know you're you
know shy away from some of these details
but in the book you really drill down I
know like what exactly you were doing
yeah it was it was heavy usage yeah it
was really heavy it's funny we have
these conservative donors in Chicago who
are a little older and they just read
the book and they reported back to our
team and they said he was so much worse
than I ever thought yeah I mean I don't
know if they had given it boy it was he
wasn't he wasn't over selling the
darkness yeah I think um and that's one
of the reasons I really wanted to write
the book was was to show people that
there it's never too late right your
past doesn't need to define you and I
think as you get in you know get through
kind of section one or whatever you're
like wow that guy's way worse than me
yeah I mean you need to be sitting on
richer old talking about you know clean
drinking water for the world I mean my
chances are good at turning the page so
you know I have this section two of my
life this kind of dark period and and
just a whole lot of yeah all right so
you didn't go there yeah I mean you know
there's the there's the part where you
know your partner Odie's on heroin and
then you've got this bouncer who is
threatening your life and your house
with a gun you know like this is it was
you know it's very cinematic yes yes
and and I had health issues so I don't
you know again when you are able to
write a book this is a long form you
know it's kind of like a 10-hour podcast
right so I really remembered that part
of one of the big things going on was
just my half my body went numb yeah so
after ten years of partying I just I
started to break down and what's what's
so interesting and very literary about
that is is how it symbolizes the
numbness of the soul mm-hmm right like
your body starts to go numb but it's
really this spiritual malaise just come
upon you yeah and in some ways it was a
betrayal the true me I think was the
caregiver was a kid who wanted to be a
doctor growing up to help sick people
like my mom it was the kid who had a
faith and who had a deep sense of virtue
and morality so this was really the you
know that and what I love in that
prodigal son story like the the prodigal
son goes halfway across the world
gambling prostitutes and then he winds
up he runs out of money and he winds up
at the end of himself and he says I want
to come home the servants in my parents
house are treated better than the
condition that I'm living in now and you
just get this sense there's like a
longing to return to like he was wrong
you know he the the exploration had led
him to a really dark place and but but
there the darkness is this incredible
teachable moment right it's almost like
I mean do you think that you could have
created what you've created without
exploring the dark side like you had to
test the boundaries of your faith to
really understand who you are you know
and yeah when I see people who are
venturing into that like we're like oh
we got to pull them out of that we got
to like help him you know he's going
wayward and it's like well maybe not so
fast maybe that person is on their
journey and they need to explore what
that's like in order to fully understand
you know who they are like it's these
are divine moments yeah I think and
we're going to judge them but they can
ultimate
I mean you're an incredible example of
how they can catalyze a life well-lived
yep hey great um you know and I was
lucky to get out so not everybody gets
out you know there were there were
people that you know had gone wayward
and then overdosed and then died we
under a lot of funerals yeah so you know
I know I don't I don't know that we
should be you know encouraging like I
needed I think I needed more of those
positive voices you know it's
interesting so I for those that don't
know my story I wind up quitting
everything at 28 years old and walking
away from that lifestyle and asking
myself the question what would the
opposite of my life look like not a
pivot not a twenty or fifty degree shift
because I actually tried that for a few
months this kind of one foot in one foot
out what would what would the clean
break look like and yeah
I the guy with a gun chasing right
perfect moment and it was exactly and
the clean break looked like go to the
poorest country in the world post-war
Liberia become a photojournalist on a
humanitarian medical mission and then
quit all devices in one go in one fell
swoop and you know I it's funny somebody
asked me recently they said so many
people are struggling with addiction and
struggling with trying to change their
life what I realized actually just this
week was one of the one of the really
important things was I changed my
environment so radically my environment
had been clubs excess drinking
debauchery sex drugs and my environment
changed to a group of humanitarian
doctors and nurses and surgeons who were
giving the best of themselves in service
to the poor so I went into this
completely healthy environment where the
new norm was selflessness the new norm
was virtue and courage and tenacity and
hard work you know in in the direction
of others in the direction of serving
others and it just looks so good I mean
I didn't want to do any of that stuff I
mean I don't want to go down off the
ship and have a cigarette you know next
to the you know
the engineers in the engine room I
wanted to really embrace this this new
lifestyle it looked so much better so I
think that really helped me never go
back because it was there was one night
where I smoked three packs of cigarettes
I drank a ton and I just I walked away
from it you know I haven't had a drag in
15 years I I haven't touched coke or any
of that stuff I having gambled in 15
years I haven't looked in a pornographic
image in 15 years like I really made a
clean break and for me I felt like I
could turn the page and start over I
mean it really felt like a do-over
at 28 mm-hmm if I had if I could
actually get rid of the crap if I could
kind of leave the detritus and there was
something so beautifully symbolic about
this ship this 522 foot hospital ship
crammed full of amazing selfless people
and I would leave all of the you know
the nasty crap on land I would walk up
the gangway and I would sail away to a
new continent and into a new life
uh-huh there was just something so
beautiful about that idea the cinematic
aspect continues to unfold these moments
I'm super interested in them and and how
they work I mean I think on some level
we're all you know all of us everybody
is visited with moments like these
moments of self-reflection that if we're
aware enough and we have enough
willingness can be transformative but I
think it's a fun you know it's like you
were able to do it for others those
moments may come and pass and they don't
have the wherewithal or the the the
degree of presence of mind or whatever
it is to actually activate on them like
what do you think I mean was it just
desperation like what what was it about
you in that frame of mind that that
allowed you to really grab that rope and
make that change I think I just caught a
vision for a new life what what it would
look like um you know I met I mentioned
dr. Gary earlier
just even hearing about someone who had
changed his life right I mean going on
the plastic surgeon track to then hit
20-some years on a ship that level of
committee commitment that little level
of dedication I just found it so
inspiring so I had this role model I had
a new role model so if the previous role
model was maybe the richest club owner
right with all the girls and all the
drugs the new role model was a great
humanitarian right like I met Albert
Schweitzer or mother Teresa and so I I
think I got a picture of I also got a
picture of how my skills might be useful
in a very different context so what I
was good at was promoting promoting
things promoting parties really I mean
to be successful in nightlife you have
to get people to turn up at your club
versus other people's uh-huh and you
have to write in this story the right
people right and that's that's often
really beautiful girls and really rich
rich people your rich guy is really who
want to hang out with the beautiful
girls and that was the whole scene we
called it models and bottles models and
bottles with the two elements and if you
did those two things you could sell
$50,000 of alcohol in a couple hours and
there would be I remember people would
come in and drop ten thousand on their
Amex they wouldn't even open the
champagne so yeah say we just buy it so
to be successful with that I was telling
the story that if you got past the
velvet rope if you made your way into
the right table and you sat with the
right people and you spend all this
money you know showing off your wealth
then your life had meaning mm-hmm and
that was the wrong story but I think I
realized in that moment I'd be able to
tell a redemptive story a story about
people like dr. Gary Parker a story
about the people that he was operating
on that he was saving the lives of and I
could tell the story to the same people
you know I had this club list of 15,000
emails yeah and back then you know the
open rate but the rich guy was like well
what about the models so I think I was
surprised sure I got I got some of them
because the the list went from getting
invited to an MTV party or the opening
of the prom
mega store in SoHo two pictures of
horrific facial tumors cleft lips cleft
palates flesh-eating disease leprosy and
and then the the answers to these
maladies and sure some people say hey
take me off the list that's gross
I didn't sign up for you know Liberia
101 but I was surprising how few people
said that I was I think I was really
struck by how people said this is
amazing I want to help how do I give
money how do I sponsor the next surgery
how do I become you I remember this
woman from Chanel wrote me once and she
said tears are just streaming down my
face it's it's lunch hour people think
that I've lost a family member and I
just can't stop uncontrollably sobbing
because I feel so moved by the suffering
and these amazing doctors that are
meeting that suffering so I think I
learned that that those same promoting
skills could be redeemed in an instant
yeah and I could tell stories that
matter yeah so when you're when you were
a club promoter you developed this email
list and then when you segue into the
work that you now do it was an
interesting time where email marketing
was just beginning right and so you were
able to convert this list from one
interest to another and take advantage
of the fact that at the time you could
get essentially a hundred percent open
rates yeah your content was being read
yeah I mean unless they unsubscribe they
were they were getting it and it was
such a visual content - I think I
understood early on that I just heard
something yesterday which I think it's
one of the best quotes I've heard in a
while and it's from Carl Jung and it
says transformation is only possible in
the presence of images transformation is
only possible in the presence of images
and I didn't know this at the time but
my instinct was to show and not tell so
the emails were super visual I took
fifty thousand photographs that first
year on the mission I was just running
around with my camera saying here's what
I'm seeing here's what I'm seeing
a little boy with a big tumor here's the
doctor in surgery operating on his face
here's the little boy without the tumor
being welcomed back into his village
surrounded by a hundred friends and
family who are celebrating his return to
life and to health and the images the
stories that were going out were driven
by these photos the words were almost ii
and i think this it just it really
worked you know so many charities I
think convey the problem through
statistics you know if I tell you or
anybody rich 663 million people today
are living without clean drinking water
you look at me with that face the
difference between 663 and a billion or
two hundred million or twenty thousand
it's hard it's hard for the human brain
to really comprehend so that's why these
stories and these images if I open up my
laptop and I said hey here's a child
that I just met a few weeks ago in
Malawi and this is the water that she's
drinking and this is what her mom looks
like and this is her house and this is
her school and this is how far her
school is from the house and actually
she can't go to school because she has
to go and get dirty water she's been six
six times this year right then then
you're immediately drawn into it but you
know I found that it was one thing to
talk about dirty water and it was
another to show it and it just moved
people in a visceral way so you know a
lot of things were just happening it
that I was just exploring could my email
list be used for good and so maybe there
was 10 years of debauched relationships
weren't wasted after all maybe they
could be redeemed
maybe the skills of promoting I could
promote something completely different
like I promote something meaningful
I could promote radical generosity and
compassion and empathy I could promote
clean drinking water for the world so I
was just making all of these discoveries
without that much perspective at the
time it's just doing stuff it was just a
flurry of activity right I mean you have
this lightbulb moment that that water is
what's behind your your with all these
doctors they're treating out of these
horrible conditions and you you begin to
understand that these conditions are all
downstream of one fundamental problem
which is that these people don't have
acts
to clean water if we can focus on the
water problem then we don't need
stadiums full of feet ball with tumors
yet rolling on their faces that's right
that's right and it begins really with
like what I love about it is it just
begins with one well mm-hmm right like
you take you come back to New York you
throw a party everybody's the only and
you had 20 bucks in that lucite box and
you build one well it's almost like a I
don't know if you had a grand vision at
the time as to what this could become
but just executing on like one task as
proof of concept yeah and then you do
your next and then you do your next and
then you do next and now there's twenty
nine thousand I mean did you have an
idea at that time that this could be
what I do you have perspective on what
you've built when you when you think
about Scott you know 15 years ago 12
years ago you may not like this answer
but at the beginning and and and this
almost I don't want to over spiritual
eyes this but I felt like I had a vision
and I could see the end and the end was
the day on earth when everyone has clean
water so I could see the per I would and
I like that answer well because most
people said so most people are saying
hey one of the questions I get a lot is
here were 12 years in we've raised 330
million dollars and we've helped 8
million people get clean water and and
the question I most often get is wow
charity water has been so successful did
you ever think you'd do all this did you
ever think you'd be so successful and
the real answer to that is this I
thought would be infinitely more
successful this is a fraction of what I
imagined at the beginning we have done
so much less then I think we should have
by now I really thought it'd be billions
so so so it's it so I did have the
vision and it did start with one well I
didn't know that it was gonna work but
but the intention was I am going to give
the rest of my life to try and end what
I see on earth as the biggest problem
facing people which is the lack of
access to clean water and then I'm gonna
start with one well and then there's two
wells and there's five wells but I did
kind of
you know I'm moving towards this day
when we all celebrate victory it's a
party actually it's a party at the end
it's the party when the entire world has
turned water so when you started it was
1.1 billion
yep and now it's at 663 right yes so
it's about haft you and other people
other organizations have essentially
have this even as population growth has
grown a decade plus right and there's a
lot more awareness but you feel like you
should be further along yes good you
kidding yeah it's clean drinking water
I mean charity water gives away a
hundred percent of all donations you
know to so I I'm just I'm I'm sometimes
baffled at how we have been unable to
move the trillions of dollars that are
just sitting in bank accounts and donor
advised funds that are that are helping
no one and we have not yet been able to
tell compelling enough stories to move
that money to helping people get clean
drinking and you're in your mind is the
biggest roadblock storytelling what is
what is the impediment it's moving
people from paralyzing apathy that that
is so easy to embrace when it comes with
these huge global issues into action
into hey I could do something mm-hmm and
I think we have been pretty good at that
by telling the stories of a
nine-year-old who's donating their
birthday to raise a couple hundred
dollars and a few people get clean water
or an 89 year old at the end of her life
you know who's giving from her pension
because you know she wants other people
to live to be eighty nine and have that
same chance I mean I would say that you
have been masterful in that I mean if
you can just continue to scale what
you're doing
the problem is inevitably going to be
solved and I think fundamentally what
charity water has done with your
stewardship is not only completely
revolutionized and changed the face of
what giving is and looks like and and
how it engages the donor but it almost
functions more like a studio like a
Hollywood studio than like Eunice
because what you trade in is
storytelling like you're working on the
emotional impact that you can have on on
the public by doing this amazing job of
telling the stories of the people that
are impacted and engaging the donors on
a level where they really feel like not
only are they make each individual is
making a tangible difference but they're
engaged they're engaged in the process
and they're engaged in the results yeah
I think storytelling you know if we had
to keep one thing and go back and do it
all over again I would take storytelling
over the hundred-percent model I would
take storytelling over you know photos
and GPS and all the cool tracking stuff
charity:water does I think that's what
moves people you know that is the that
is kind of them and that's what I teach
other social entrepreneurs you have to
be able to go and tell true stories that
matter I think a lot of people want to
help and we talked about the last time
we were together so many people look at
the suffering around the world and they
say I wish I could do something but then
there's this lack of trust there's this
I don't trust the system I don't know
how much of my money would actually get
to those people you know I don't know
that it's gonna make an impact and
they're all these barriers so we have
been through the charity water business
model trying to break down those
barriers and say to the cynics say to
the skeptic take another look because I
actually believe people are depriving
themselves of the blessing and the joy
that comes with giving by by all those
excuses so I just haven't done enough of
that I mean yes we've gotten a million
people and they've given generously from
a hundred countries
I really believe the best is yet to come
so I think in in year where we just
finished 12 years of charity water I
actually do think the best is yet to
come I mean today we're gonna get 4,000
new people clean drinking water for the
first time in their life then we do it
again tomorrow right and again the next
day and again the next day now I want
that number to be 40,000 but it's it's
now significant you know the eight and a
half million people
we've helped it's more than the
population of New York City and all the
borough's you know we're starting to add
up you
seven states worth the people in impact
while and it's 178th of the global
problem so you put eight and a half
million into the current 663 and 178
like that sounds better than 1/1000
right like let's do 78 times more
let's invite 78 times more people to
participate let's you know let's invite
more people to the party
uh-huh so backtracking to how you can't
kind of conceptualize this at the outset
I think what you said is is is very true
that there are so many it's it's now
changed in the last decade but when you
at the outset of charity:water
there's this tremendous distrust about
charitable organization it hasn't
changed that much by the way how's data
hasn't changed really I mean you know
outside of any better charities like a
lot of the young charities that have
started have adopted these values yeah
they basically you know mocked your your
value system and your your your model
maybe not the hundred percent model but
the idea of creating transparency is
between donor and results is certainly
been implemented across the board with
great success and I think that's changed
the face of how people give and how they
think about giving but your idea at the
beginning was like okay let's not
bombard people with statistics and guilt
let's create an inspiring brand that
gets people excited and want to
participate and let's inject them with
that feeling
Suzy you have yeah which is what it
feels like when you're of service and
you give we're all walking around you
know trying to keep up with the Joneses
and you know get that salary bump so we
can get the new car and we're chasing
the dragon on this illusion of the
American Dream when the truth of what
we're actually seeking which is
fulfillment and purpose and and and
happiness and joy is is available to us
if if we can just make that leap of
faith into what it feels like to to give
right and it's almost like you rescued
that away from a broken system
that is almost predatory in how it makes
us feel badly about ourselves to one
that inspires people and and shares this
sense of what it what it what it
actually feels like when your life is in
devotion to the betterment of others
well said that's that's so articulated I
mean that is that is the vision you know
the mission of charity water is to bring
clean water to people on earth and
that's a very clear mission mission is
accomplished when no human being on
earth is drinking dirty water but the
vision is actually much softer it's it's
it's some of the things you just said
it's to to bring people back to the true
meaning of charity charity means love it
means to look after your neighbor in
need and get nothing in return
and I was so upset that word that this
it's become tainted for so many people
in charity is a bad thing
not a good thing like we need more love
in this world I mean look around yeah
right we need more people agreeing to
agree on serving others on ending
needless suffering of using our time in
our talent and our money to to help
people to improve the world and I just
thought that the way most people most
charities approach this was wrong like
you said it was shame it was guilt it
was you you have too much you know you
should even even that the language
giving back I loathe this language
giving back you hear everywhere it's in
the lexicon now right oh I'm giving back
our companies giving back that makes it
sound like we have pillaged and
plundered to such extent that we should
finally throw a few scraps down to the
poor let's give a little bit back so
let's nach something you know if I take
your phone out of your hand you're gonna
say give it back right right why don't
we drop the back we should just we
should frame giving in the positive we
are just giving what's build a culture
of giving in our family in our company
maybe in our faith community let's give
because we can because we want to
because it's it's a blessing not out of
opportunity or sorry not out of you know
guilt or shame or debt or obligation but
because it is a
an amazing opportunity to share our
blessing with others and I actually
would love to get people addicted to
giving you know it's funny my my my
ambition right now around money and I'm
43 I've got you know beautiful wife and
two kids but my ambition around money is
to give more away is to personally give
more away yeah someone and I write about
this someone many years ago wrote a
million-dollar check that changed the
game for charity water it was an
inflection point and it took us from the
brink of insolvency because we had
retired last time yeah we hadn't rented
out I want to do that for somebody else
yeah like I just have this dream of one
day I don't know how I'm gonna do it on
a charity salary but one day I would
love to walk into someone else's office
a young social entrepreneur and not just
give them advice okay because I can give
a lot of people advice but I would like
to actually so that's the ambition not
the house in the Hamptons not the
Mercedes or the Tesla you know not the
vacation you know the Four Seasons and
that that's really true you know and in
some ways it's freeing because I'm I
don't feel trapped yeah I not have you
know the next like the minute I would
get the Tesla I'm sure I'd want a better
car you know or the minute I went on
that vacation well somebody went on an
even nicer vacation or stayed at the
nicer hotel in the island right so
there's it's been so freeing twelve
years ago to just step off of that rat
race and think about think about how I
can be useful I can be a vessel I think
people would think of you or who don't
really understand you or what you do or
somebody similar to you as like martyrs
like oh you know they're like like your
your your your flogging yourself and
your hair shirt and you know that
because you know you can't stand the
suffering of others but you're one of
the happiest people that I know right
like you're you're a living example of
how great you can feel and how good your
life experience can be when you're when
you're in that mode right to give more
like you're in a place right now you've
how much have you raised through
yeah okay 330 million I don't know what
your salary is but it's a charity salary
I would imagine that if the board of
charity water came to you and said
listen Scott like let's just double your
salary you're doing a great job that the
donor base would celebrate that they're
like Scott should be you know getting
paid more but knowing you a little bit I
would imagine you would just like give
that away right like you what we do we
give 20% of them away right right so
you're even of this salary that they
give you when everything that you do is
for the charity you're still giving it
does that does that go back into charity
water or you've some other it's funny we
am I had them pull the numbers recently
just I was like why might get some
really hard questions about do you give
your own organization and since we
started we've given my wife and I've
given a hundred eighty-five thousand of
our salary back to charity water haha
and you know that's 18 wells which is
like a total joy to be able to do so we
give to our local church we give to
charity water we give to other charities
there's probably 20 other organizations
we support but we're fine it's not a
martyr I live in a you know in a 1,200
square foot two-bedroom you know really
nice apartment in New York City seven
minutes from my office in Battery Park
City in Tribeca
I Drive a Kia Sorento that's Elise I
love my Kia right it's got the two car
seats installed in the back like we we
have food on the table we have you know
I fly coach that sucks I'm you know 43
and I'm 6 foot 1 14 hours on air
Ethiopian is not a fun experience but
you know there that that's like that's
the worst of it like that is the worst
of it mm-hmm so we have these amazing I
mean it's just an amazing life like I
get to in Batu 69 countries amid the
Ethiopia 30 times I get to I get to I
get to preach a message of generosity of
trying to invite people into something
really beautiful for them you know
invite them into transformation through
selflessness you know one of the things
I talk about you know the end of the
book is this idea of work that has no
end
and if you can for me it was it was
selfishness with no end
it was accumulation with no end you know
it was it was more girls more drugs more
you know cars things watches better
clothes and for the last 12 years it's
been more for others more more resources
more time more energy spent to try to
make the world a better place to try to
help people who have nothing you know
who are truly suffering and that isn't
never-ending work but I've just come to
embrace that yeah and I think that you
know I love the one well idea that you
brought up because it did start with one
and then there were five and then there
were ten and it's it's like that
Nietzsche quote of you know the long
obedience in the same direction one day
if you just keep showing up you turn
around and you like oh well that's
29,000 was and and you know check in
like maybe I come back on three years
and like who knows what that is or maybe
some other amazing things have happened
because you just keep showing up and you
know that I I think we're at the
beginning you know I think like this is
this is the beginning of the journey I
hope that I would be able to put in 30
years like dr. Garry Parker and look
back I mean think of how many surgeries
he's done now you probably signed up for
a few surgeries so I'm gonna go over and
fix a couple cleft lips and cleft
palates and I'm gonna go back to my
practice in California then we make a
lot of money and you know has it been
tens of thousands of people he's
operated on now who never would have
gotten operation had he not said yes
that he not answered the call do not
fear work that has no end
it's a pinnacle it is it comes from an
obscure rabbinic text said somebody took
a picture of that quote outside of
bodega 10 years ago in New York City and
I just I love that it's like the call to
you know infinite giving right I think
along the way there's been these amazing
kind of examples of almost divine
providence and I think that the most
sort of crystallized examples of that
are kind of how you went from office
space to office space where at the last
minute somebody would come in and and
like these problems would get something
ly impossible problems yeah it would get
solved through
generosity of people inspired by the
work that you guys are doing and their
stuff I couldn't even write about in the
book because it would feel too creepy I
mean you know my editors like cuz I
would I mean I looked the we talked
about this lesson the organization is
not a religious organization it never
has been
I you know pray I have a just a I guess
a nondenominational kind of Christian
faith and I have seen so many direct
clear answers to prayer I mean we had to
take it out of the book cause it just
felt and some of this stuff just felt
like too over the top but there was a
moment when we didn't have an office
space we were working out of this Soho
loft my old club partner was just raging
all the time and you know he would bring
people back that would do drugs and I
was sleeping on a closet floor when
charity:water started and I go up on the
roof and you know I'm just praying him
like God we need to get out of here like
we need to get out of here we didn't
have money we we could barely afford an
office and I finished praying and at
that moment I checked my blackberry and
someone has just sent an email about an
office space that they heard we were
looking and no ly rich I can see it from
the roof uh-huh I can see our new office
building uh-huh it's five blocks away so
they're all these just crazy stories
where you know we have had that when
we're on the brink of bankruptcy in year
two and the organization is gonna become
insolvent and I'm shutting down charity
water and there is no more charity water
I'm praying for some sort of miracle and
you know an atheist as it would happen
walks into my office sits with me and
writes a million-dollar check complete
stranger it's insane you know and and
like so it's just it's it's been really
cool to see and and these little
confirmations I think I've just said
you're on the right path you're on the
right path keep keep showing up like
this is what you're supposed to be doing
you've found your purpose your calling
or just don't don't give up don't quit
yeah don't compromise you know your
values and that's one of the the lessons
you know in that story in the book you
know before that million dollar miracle
gift we we could have done the wrong
thing we could have borrowed a huge
amount of money that was in the account
for the water projects that we'd
promised the public we would never touch
right like the fidelity to the the value
system and the integrity and I would
imagine as you as you grow larger
there's perhaps temptations to divert
from your core values because of this
that or the other sort of compromise
that you could make and and and even
perhaps justifiable in that you know the
end would justify the means but how do
you you know maintain that like focus on
the principles that launched it from the
get-go
we've made it cultural I mean this it's
it's so black and white so there your
absolute that would be a decision it's
like okay well so we had we had a so so
part of the money you know coming in
from the spring is also able to be used
to repair projects and bring them back
online right like a rehabilitation of a
well is is the same as a new well for us
in our mind but you know somebody said
once well hey we're we need to go and
build some sensors which are gonna help
us track the sustainability of these
projects and we said no we can't use
that money gotta go raise it separately
because the ten year old girl who's
doing five lemonade stands wants to give
new people clean water not work on a
technology that's a little more abstract
now you could argue that sensor is gonna
let us know when the well breaks we're
gonna send a mechanic like it is mall in
the service of clean drinking water
flowing but we just said I wanna raise
that's ever write letter to that little
girl saying oh it actually might be okay
the little girl might be like hey great
you know I paid for a sustainability
program but we just we keep coming back
to you know let's let's try to make the
hard decisions I mean credit card fees
like it's insane that we pay back credit
card fees I mean this does not make
sense if you give a hundred dollars a
month on your Amex and I get ninety
seven a month which is what we get we
pay back the three dollars every single
month and we send your intended hundred
now you wouldn't expect us to send more
money than we actually got from your
donation but we said well we don't
really like we can say a hundred percent
if it's ninety seven percent just
running a perpetual deficit then yeah so
those the
130 families that pay for the overhead
and pay back those credit-card
transaction fees it's hundreds of
thousands of dollars now just to make up
the difference but we wanted to be able
to just stand up there and say a hundred
percent means a hundred percent yeah
faith is a huge part of who you are and
it informs the work that you do and it's
an interesting arc coming from you know
a relatively evangelical upbringing to
you know losing your way and finding
your way back and and you're relatively
open about that aspect of your life
although you're always careful to kind
of not preach yeah not not preaching and
just make sure that you know your
message is nondenominational in every
regard but I appreciated the fact that
in the book you you you go into a little
bit more depth about that and how
important it is to you so I'm interested
in how you think of like how you think
about faith in that aspect of you know
how you came to become this person and
how it how it does you know inform your
work and continue to kind of propel you
yeah well I think at 28 I rediscovered
you know the teachings of Jesus or the
the personhood of Jesus in a very
different way and he was a lot more
exciting with fresh eyes he was a
radical he was a rebel he was more like
me in that he was you know rejecting the
oppressive religious establishment of
the day and saying hey let's serve the
poor hey let's be pure I mean you know
he was calling the religious leaders you
know whitewashed tombs snakes you know
all these horror but he was just
constantly offending them and I think
that's what I had taken the most umbrage
to growing up was the kind of the
religiosity you know it felt oppressive
it felt real based it just felt like all
the things I wasn't allowed to do like
you guys are just you're putting me into
this box so I think having then done all
those things found certainly nothing but
but heartache or brokenness in those
coming back I was so taken by the purity
of Jesus I mean he was above reproach
he'd not he
refused to play into the system in the
world he had no earthly possessions yes
he was living from place to place and
speaking truth to power in this kind of
affair like you know like his Rob Bell
talks about it like his very punk rock
it's very like Rage Against the Machine
yes have you been to hit have you seen
his um his Christmas show that he that
he does the new one now he was we were
just together recently he's talking
about a boss I heard it's all about kind
of the things that you were just
mentioning yeah and then but Jesus spend
so much time talking about the poor and
he spends so much time with you know
that the outcasts the people that know
that would walk by his parables you know
these the parable of like the Good
Samaritan just spoke to me the you know
I was the guy walking by I was a guy
that never had time and you know Jesus
is celebrating the person who stops and
who picks up you know the person lying
in the street and checks them into the
hotel and puts down the AMEX and says
I'll just cover all the expenses you
know until they get well so I just found
the opposite of my life the opposite
intention of my life so compelling and
you know I am I have a I guess I have
such a pattern now of praying expecting
an answer and then getting an answer
that like my prayer life is just uh I
don't know I mean I listen I believe I'm
talking to somebody and and they are
hearing I mean there was a story we
couldn't write about in the book I just
I remember we were in the middle of
northern Ethiopia and I don't think I've
ever told this story before I was with
Vic we weren't married at the time and
we were in this this really kind of bad
hotel at the top of the hill and we were
all it was New Year's Eve in Ethiopia
there on the Julian calendar which is
fascinating so it doesn't line up with
December 31st and we we got for pizza
the night before at a restaurant get up
in the morning and we're about to fly
back and they can't find her passport
and actually she can't find her bag and
it turns out her bag was stolen so I
send the rest of the group there were
ten other people back home I cancel my
flight and we are looking for her
passport now our local partner is kind
of he's the man
Caillat Ethiopia so he gets all the cops
to turn up they start knocking on the
doors of the known criminals in this
town you know hustling them searching
you know because this is a huge offense
when a foreigner comes in and has their
possession stolen it was her wallet her
camera in her passport and so I just
start praying and I'm like God show me
where the passport would be I kid you
not I feel like I can just see where
this and I feel like God says it's under
the bushes behind the hotel come on so
I'm like I'll be right back
and I take one of the guys with me and I
crawl kind of over this fenced-in area
and there's a big bush and I walk behind
it and her bag has been hidden under the
tree oh my god and we got on the next
plane and what had happened was they
think one of the workers had stolen it
had then scared right to be caught with
the contraband as the cops flood this
hotel so they ditch it believe me and so
many prayers have have gone unanswered I
just I just lost my mom to pancreatic
cancer four months ago here and I was I
was praying until the end I was praying
for a miracle
I had pastors you know people in my
faith community around the world
praying and God took her you know I mean
it was she she died in in hospice and
four months from diagnosis to to death
so believe me as as great as that is
like to find a you know to find a wallet
under a bush or and I mean there's just
so many examples over the years that
again I didn't want to like putting in
the book because I don't want to freak
people out and and think that you know
I'm completely nuts yeah but I do really
make it like a religious text yeah
becomes inaccessible for somebody they
didn't they lose that they lose sight of
what it is that you're actually trying
to say here but I think there is
something really compelling about this
idea of looking to the example of Jesus
who is this amazing
who was able to like embody these ideals
that we all aspire to but false so short
of and to say what would it be like if I
actually tried to model my life after
his behavior like forget about all the
trappings of religion religion is just
like well this guy did this this this
and this and this is how he behaved and
this is how he interacted with people
like what would it actually be like if I
tried to do that and then ya really have
done that and your life has changed
dramatically and impacted people all
over the world and you're not like
walking around barefoot you know you
know in a beggar's robe like you're
living you're a modern guy living in the
modern world in New York City but I
think there's a lot of inspiration that
we can take from that example of what
it's like to just be like I keep going
back to this but like to be in this mode
of giving and service and yeah and exude
and approaching situations from a
perspective of how can I contribute to
make this better
as opposed to what can I extract out of
this to accumulate for my own you know
to account for my own inadequacies or
insecurities well the last thing I'd say
about faith was just um you know Jesus
always talked about the kingdom like the
kingdom of God the kingdom of God
there's just this language all through
like bringing the kingdom of God to
earth and the nice thing about the last
twelve years of my work with
charity:water is that even though it's a
completely secular and non-religious
organization I feel like I get to bring
what I imagine the kingdom would look
like to earth through clean water
because I know that in and heaven right
everybody might have a different opinion
of what that might look like but I know
pretty much everybody would agree in
heaven no one's drinking dirty water
dirty is illegal in everyone's version
of heaven oh girl walking eight hours
with 40 pounds of disgusting river water
on her back getting raped during that
walk illegal it's not happening so in
like the in the most basic theology I
through my work through my you know non
evangelical work really that involves
Muslims and Jews and atheists and Hindus
and Buddhists and Mormons like I get to
and you know people of all faiths people
of no-face Republicans Democrats
independents I get to create this huge
tent but my theology of helping people
get clean drinking water huh it is in
line with the work which is a really
freeing thing and I think because you
don't have to do what I do on a Sunday
or pray to the God I pray to to work at
the organization or give to the
organization and in fact most people
don't
that's almost giving me a freedom to say
well this is what I believe and this is
my story yeah and you can't spend funny
just reading the reviews on amazon of
the book so many people are like i would
never read a religious book uh-huh and
i'm jewish or I'm an atheist but it was
okay it was okay he didn't try and
convert me he didn't train but he's not
a religious but it isn't at all it isn't
no but you know for anybody like I mean
I talk about prayer and some of these
you know some of these moments of answer
to prayer or or how I tried to
re-experience faith and you know some
people like anything having to do with
faith is just completely timid right
this but it was interesting people like
it was okay I'm giving the pass because
they didn't preach ormally and normally
no yeah I'm telling you if you read the
reviews it's funny it's like normally I
would never read anything with any
religious overtone but if you know
there's a big but why minute that speaks
to in the same way that we you know we
have this crisis around giving and
charity the same can be said for our
religious institutions you know if you
were to say you know oh you need to give
back or you know UNICEF is knocking on
the door you're like you know really
similarly for a lot of people just
saying the word religion or Christianity
or g.od or any of these things perjures
yeah you know provokes a an emotional
reaction that's we´d to some childhood
experience or something like that and
and in many ways you know the best of
what faith-based organ
Asians have to offer you know could use
a little Scott Harrison rebranding in
certain respects you know well certainly
the transparency would be for head yeah
so where are we at right now we we're at
663 still in need still in need how long
he's grown yeah so your your commuters
have since since that started there are
now 30 29,000 people from 104 countries
including countries in Africa which
makes me so happy so there are people
that are given monthly to the spring
from Africa that have heard about it
it's interesting to say spring is your
monthly subscription so Netflix for
clean water or Spotify ever clean water
a hundred percent of of what people give
monthly goes straight out the door
provides clean water we're then able to
share stories of impact and that that
has been that that's the future for us
because the drive by one-time gift or
the one-time birthday doesn't help you
solve the water crisis right someone
listening and says oh I'm gonna give a
hundred bucks once I gotta go find the
next person in the next year so getting
someone who says well I think I could
maybe sign up for this idea for a while
like I could sign up for the idea of a
world where everyone has clean drinking
water and I can trust this organization
and and that's again why I would hope
you know the so many of our values are
in that book so you will get a sense at
the end of it of who we are what
animates us what values we really care
about and we're hoping just build keep
growing a community of people who you
know who keeps showing up like every
month in month out in the same way that
we show up for our content you know in
the same way we show up for Dropbox and
we want to you know access our photos
can we get people to show up for for
others for clean water so that's now
grown 29,000 people in a hundred
countries that the fascinating thing is
the average across the community is
exactly thirty dollars a month which is
what which is what it costs us to give
one person clean water then we have kids
giving a ten we have people giving it
100 but it's just amazing to see that
organic
average is 29,000 people every month are
getting 29,000 new people clean drinking
water and that's the number I want to
add a zero to it's a great model for for
a lot of reasons but also because it
solves a dilemma that I know that that
you have historically faced every year
which is that much money raised in a
year you got to start over from zero and
January 1 was a dark day doing this at
some point you know working 80-hour
weeks like it's gonna catch up to you
and you're gonna burn out right like so
I know you've kind of thought it up
against the edges yeah of what that
feels like yeah I mean I wrote about
that too I for years people were saying
that I would burn out and I'd be like
I'm still here did ninety eight flights
last year 150 speeches look at me not
burned out yet and it took it took about
nine years and and there was a really
dark moment where I did I did want to
quit and I managed to come out of it and
I actually hoped that writing about that
experience but in fact other social
entrepreneurs have told me other
entrepreneurs in general have said hey I
felt there I've been there the way that
I came out of it was was realizing that
I had put so much of my personal
identity in the success of the
organization so when charity water was
doing well I was doing well and charity
water had done well for eight
consecutive years and then the ninth
year when we didn't do so well when our
donations dipped for the first time
Scott didn't do well and I became
depressed and it's all my fault and I'm
letting people down actually felt like
I'd I'd let hundreds of thousands of
people down because we hadn't repeated
the success of the previous year we
hadn't grown and there was a there was a
really important time and lesson that I
learned which was okay I am more than my
organization you know I'm a father of
two I'm a husband and actually in that
year outside of the money that we raised
it was our best year we didn't
compromise our values or our integrity
we pushed sustainability forward our
team had a great year we hired some
extraordinary people that we on-boarded
it's just we didn't raise as much money
so that that kind of led to me saying
all right I'm not gonna quit I'm gonna
come back and I'm gonna try and launch
the spring and actually solve this
problem which is we are too big to start
at zero every January 1 and just and
invite people to show up with us on a
longer-term basis yeah and your
community again was so helpful I think
yeah I don't know I did I forget how
much but I think they were they joined
it like over a hundred thousand dollars
a month just renewed action to the
community out there they still have a
link up that I think I do but I'm gonna
end this with a with another call to
action but for now I will say that if
you're new to the show and you're
listening to this and and you're not a
member of the spring that you should
sign up immediately I think I do have a
link I'll put links up at the show notes
to all of that and you know you guys can
dig deeper in the I'll put a bunch of
other links about Scott and the work
that he does and certainly pick up his
book where you can learn more about the
amazing work that this organization is
doing but I can tell you it's been a
delight and a pleasure to be a spring
member and to see the engagement of the
listenership of this show you have to
engage in the work that you do so I'm
amazing communicates that man so how
many times are you going to are you
traveling now overseas to oversee the
work that's going on there three times
next year it's not really overseeing the
work anymore so we have an amazing team
that does that there are 19 people at
charity:water whose full-time jobs are
flying around you know think of them out
there with clipboards making sure the
work is being done with high quality
working with our partners and then
auditing making sure the money is being
spent well so I'm typically out telling
stories or trying to recruit more
overhead donors because that's a
challenge yeah we have a million people
that have given on the water side but I
need to make sure that I can continue to
pay for our staff and our office costs
and our flights so what's the annual
budget just for managing overhead about
14 and a half million this year
and we'll raise a total of 70 mm-hmm
so we're very efficient you know we
might spend 85% of our money on programs
and 15% to run it but still that money
has to come separately so that's not a
that's not a trivial under teeth that's
like sixty percent of your time is
focused on raising money for that
yeah and it's an amazing community you
know those 131 families and
entrepreneurs that are supporting the
overhead it's the founders of Facebook
and Twitter and Spotify and WordPress
and Pandora and it's you know Apple
executives it's people like Rob Bell our
friend and people like Depeche Mode
that's a really kind of and football
quarterbacks I mean it's a it's a motley
crew of 131 families that said we got
your back we don't need our name on a
well we want to help you hire the next
hydrologist the next accountant the next
you know person to greet people at
charity water HQ will pay for the toner
for the Epson copy machine so I'm
spending a lot of time growing that
community from 131 to 135 240 and one of
the ways I do that is by taking them
over there and so I'll do 3 trips next
year I'm trying to get you there you
know I keep inviting you I know
oh you well this is actually let me air
this out with you because I had an
opportunity to go on one of these trips
and it looked like I could do it and
then I was like I just I had so much
going on and I just I couldn't I
couldn't justify breaking away to go on
this trip but I'm committed to to doing
this like I really do want to do this
and I'm at my own kind of moment right
now where I wouldn't say I'm I'm
teetering on burning out but I'm the
bottleneck and so many things that I
that I'm doing that I'm finally
embracing this idea that the things that
I've done that have got me to where I am
right now not the things that are going
to go to the next level and make some
fundamental changes and how I'm running
this you know it's a it's a very micro
version of what you're doing but it has
its own challenges and I need to let go
of certain things and bring more people
on to allow me to better scale what I'm
doing and also allow me to focus on the
things that are most important not just
professionally but personally so I can
you know have the experience a
of going on one of these trips with you
next March I'm gonna hit you I'm gonna
hit you hard we got another way that I
can plan it and I am committing to that
now yeah it'd be great I think I know
you and you would get so much life from
the trip not just from you know
community of like-minded givers you know
who who will also join them there'll be
25 people but just meeting the you know
for me I just put you guys into it and
then I get out of the way it's so great
like I just saw that bad job does itself
and you're talking with the local
drillers you know when you meet the team
running an ethiopian drilling rig of
eight guys and you say hey you know
what's what's your what's your workweek
like they're like what's our work month
like we work 29 out of 30 days take one
day off a mile yeah because there's an
eight month dry season in Ethiopia and
they want to maximize it because when it
rains for four months they can't drill
so they leave their family so you didn't
you know you're asking the questions
that you're interviewing him in um every
once in a while someone will come into
the village and say well why don't the
people just move closer to the water I'm
like once you ask the women yeah so I
just step back and you know through
translator saying hey how come you don't
move closer to the water and then women
say weirdy who owns that land we don't
know in that land this is our farm this
is where we grew up so I just love being
a part of these you know these trips as
people explore as they they're inspired
I mean yeah there's definitely some
tears you know if you're if you're there
at the moment when a thousand people are
getting clean water for the first time
in their life and you watch clean water
shoot out of the ground under pressure
as they flush the well and you see the
dancing and tears streaming down
people's faces it's uh it's really
emotional it's like a it's like a
picture of heaven yeah whatever heaven
looks like to you but it's it's an
extraordinary thing to be a part of
what's one of your favorite stories from
these experiences that you could share
you know there's there's one you know I
think I told a couple segments the last
time there's one story that I didn't get
to write about in the book and it's not
super happy but I think it's it puts a
point on
the urgency of the work so I was just
talking about the celebrations when you
drill a well and you get water is just
awesome
it's just awesome and communities will
talk about their community often as
before the water and after the water
another theme that I tease that in the
book is this before and after that's
what I was doing with mercy ship it was
this black and white so my life was
before and after you know before the
cocaine you know smoking you know crack
head basically running around and now
after like a husband a father you know a
guy who's able to lead an organization
the doctor Gary was doing before and
after I stopped getting to death with a
facial tumour and now you're fine you
know blind with a cataract now you can
see and it's the same thing with water
you're able to take it before the water
all the problems that we discussed to
after the water so there was one of
these celebrations and it was in
Ethiopia and normally everybody is happy
there's music there's lolling which is
the women just shouting at the top of
their lungs and there was one woman off
to the side who was weeping during this
and our partners go over to this she's
an older woman and they say you know why
are you crying like this is a this is a
joyful moment like look around you and
she's just like almost Oh like consumed
with rage and she says do you mean to
tell me that the water was underneath
our feet the whole time uh-huh and that
I spent my life walking hours for dirty
water to a faraway source and then it
was right there all along and that
struck me just that picture of a
thousand people celebrating a woman you
know on a ridge off to the side grieving
decades of suffering and then one day a
truck pulls in a bunch of guys jump out
start sticking a you know drilling bit
into the ground and 48 hours later they
find clean water and everything's I
think is fine so that that that picture
you know we we don't want her to suffer
for 20 or 30 years we don't want her
kids to suffer and I think when you hear
something like that now I can better
understand why you feel like you should
be further along
yeah if it really is that simple why
can't we why can't we accelerate this
and avoid those kinds of situations of
that woman when the problem is so
incredibly solvable and we're gonna try
and do that we were just talking before
about our gala and trying to fund more
drilling rigs every drilling rig
specifically in Ethiopia can drill about
85 wells a year so we're actually
limited right now by capacity we have
eight drilling rigs they're going
full-time so eight times a you got about
640 villages but you add a new rig you
get a new 85 alleges how much does a rig
cost about 750 grand mm-hmm how do you
make a decision about it how do you
decide like okay here's the next well
we're gonna have you identified every
plant that needs them and then how do
you prioritize a pecking order
so now being at a said scale in the
beginning it was just hey we got money
for ten wells drill them wherever you
want now you know when you're more at
scale there are plans there are often
three to five-year plans for different
districts and in all these countries
work and I think we're active in 17 or
18 countries this year so there would be
there's a plan for the chikuwa district
in Malawi there's a plan for the real
Indo district in Rwanda there's the plan
for two gray we know what a hundred
percent covers looks like sometimes it's
60 million to go sometimes it's 200
million to go sometimes it's fourteen
million to go and we're working towards
that hundred percent coverage so it's
not a random haphazard let's just drill
a few wells
it's a clustered approach so you bring a
new well and a new rig in you get a new
cluster in action I say so it's really
it's really exciting
yeah I'm really optimistic and what are
the what are the sort of political
hurdles that you have to jump over I
mean are you dealing with like you know
village politics and lots of
personalities and have you had pushback
and issues where you have to really
figure out how to grace people in a
certain way to make it happen yeah
people that's that surprised me and I
think it surprised a lot of people that
when it comes to water when
we're not encountering resistance now we
have said we're not working in conflict
zone so we're not working in Yemen we're
not working in Darfur Sudan you know
we're not working these places where
there's there's active war going on
we're not working in despotic countries
where the government actually doesn't
want any NGOs for that is that so meant
of revolution right but it leaves us
like 50 countries that we can work in
where the government is saying we're
doing our we're doing our part will you
come and help so that's the amazing
thing about water I mean we're making
them look good do you think when we come
in and take one district in Rwanda
alongside the Rwandan government is so
interesting they actually match our
money 90 cents on the dollar yeah I was
gonna ask why can't these governments
give you some part of their tax base to
first then if they are on you know they
are the money that they're spending is a
fraction of what's needed
uh-huh that tax base is being first of
all it's a small amount it's being split
among roads among healthcare among
energy you know power lines cell towers
water there there are all these
different things they have to do so we
are seeing government's spend money but
in in certain cases they are matching
our dollars so we've done about 12
million 12 million in Rwanda 12 million
dollars in Rwanda in the real indo
district it's a tongue tie and the
government has put 11 million alongside
ours so it's really a 22 million dollar
program over seven years and we started
it I think around 20% water coverage
we're at 99% gradually we're like we're
almost there this district has nobody
you know in a couple months we'll have
nobody drinking dirty water now we're
moving on to the districts to the side
and we're gonna start over again so it's
it's really hopeful seeing them we're
not seeing resistance you know every
once in a while you know a mayor will
come and take credit right oh my good
people you know I have brought in the
water but you don't have that the whole
beauty of the business model is that
charity water is getting everyday people
to care to act to engage to join this
community but the actual work is always
done by the locals
you know for the work to be sustainable
for it to be culturally sensitive and
appropriate it has to be led by the
locals so they get the credit so it's
amazing rolling into Ethiopia and people
don't know who charity water is but they
know and celebrate our local partner
who's running those a drilling rigs one
of the things that I thought was was
most touching at the that gala in New
York last winter was was that you had a
bunch of those people a bunch of the
locals there yeah and you and you made
such a point of you know celebrating
these individuals who are actually doing
the work
you know boots on the ground yeah again
and allowing who these people are and
like the sacrifice that they're making
to be away from their family for such
extended periods of time and you'll be
when you come in March you'll be so
inspired by them I mean you'll really
see we'll get out of the way we'll just
say hey go go go ask them Tech Lani tell
tell everybody why you do what you do so
many people are living their lives
feeling incredibly disenfranchised
they're disconnected from the fruits of
their labor from anything that that that
provides them with passion you know
they're just trying to get through the
day and pay the bills and there's this
malaise the sense that one person really
can't make a difference like yeah I can
put a quarter in the in the little box
from whoever when I'm walking into
Walmart but like is that really doing
anything and and and so I love how a big
part of the ethos of charity:water is is
helping people to really reframe that
and to really understand that one person
can make a difference a very tangible
impactful difference and with that comes
this sense of purpose that can overcome
one and in doing that you tell amazing
stories about you know everyone from the
girl with a lemonade stand to whoever so
I thought it would be nice if you could
tell one of those stories for somebody
who's listening to this who feels like
yeah I'm hearing everything Scott saying
but like you know
I don't know how I could have that kind
of feeling in my own life first let me
just I know you haven't gotten there yet
but you basically just delivered the end
of the book so I'm gonna read the last
alright boom the last line you didn't
even know where I was gonna end but
that's it so it says you know it ad last
count charity:water is funded more than
28-thousand water projects that'll help
eight and a half million people get
clean water people who will never have
to experience what it was like before
the water ever again we still have so
much work to do yet every day I wake up
hopeful that we will solve this problem
in my lifetime I believe that together
we can bring life's most basic necessity
to the 663 million people who still
don't have it I'm just one guy who built
one charity but it's made a little dent
in the water crisis next year we'll make
a bigger dent and this is how the
problems of the world gets solved one by
one by me and you in us I really believe
that beautiful like as we you know as we
all join our voices together so and on
honest story it's a new story it's not
in the book we're about to launch our
big World Water Day campaign March 22nd
at the organization we had a whole
campaign lined up and then somebody
opening up the mail at HQ gets a note
little picture and eight dollars and 15
cents and we learned it's from a
six-year-old named Nora and the note
says dear charity water I saw your video
and I'm sending in 8 dollars and 15
cents because I want kids to stop bat
dying of bad water that when kids stop
dying of bad water and she draws a
picture of herself next to a well in
Africa what she thinks of well looks
like with the clean water coming out so
charity water you know we're
storytellers like stop the presses
cancel the campaign let's see if Nora
will let us put her on camera and tell
her story so we have a camera crew down
in Virginia a week later and Nora opens
up her house the six-year-old girl and
on camera she's this precocious girl
that says well I saw the video and I
went up to my room that night and I just
I asked myself the question should I
give my money or should I keep my money
should I give my money should I keep my
and she's back and forth and it's so
cute to hear and she says so I came down
in the morning I said I would give my
money
so she drops eight dollars and fifteen
cents from her allowance and shemales it
in and ah there's so much there right
the purity of heart and by the way we're
all asking ourselves a sex the same
hushes should I guess should I not
should I trust should I not so she comes
out on the right side for her and we
launched a campaign around this
three-minute video and she's just she's
beautiful she has this heart to serve
others and when you see her on the
camera you just melt you're like I want
to be that pure I want to it like the
simplicity you had back to the pebbly
you know Jesus it little children come
to me right we will be led by children
the simplicity of children to teach
adults these these values of generosity
compassion and purity so we just told
her story and we asked everyone just to
give eight dollars and 15 cents and how
much was raised 80 grand in a day so
that's the song euni wells yeah and
she's so her seed her vision of eight
dollars and fifteen cents turned into a
thousand times more uh-huh
and what does she think of all this she
loved it hopefully we'll get shake her
there yeah it's hopefully she can go and
see some of that impact one day we do
think about that like how do we close
the loop but I would hope that even Nora
might live her life a little differently
that that the feedback loop that seeing
people respond you know might even
encourage her to give a greeting that
age and then suddenly you're the seed
that that germinates this amazing flower
that has to impact her and make her
think I mean it had to be an amazing
feeling for her yeah that is incredible
and I think it does speak perfectly to
this idea that one person really can
make a change and I love this idea of of
you know I don't unlock uh back to this
literary thing like this symbology of
like purity is there anything more pure
than water like taking it back to its
biblical roots and the the way that we
all cleanse ourselves our bodies and our
souls through clean water right and
that's
essentially what this is all about the
clarity of purpose and and the
simplicity of what water represents and
how powerful it is he's really amazing
so great let's close this down if you
could just leave us with a thought about
what it means to to live a life of
service and and and how you think about
that and and you know without repeating
what we've already talked about what you
think it would mean for another person
to extend themselves in service and and
and the comic downstream impact of that
freedom is the first word that comes to
mind I mean for me and I can only speak
for me I just found such a freedom in
redirecting the intention of my life
away from accumulation and selfishness
and status and you know all the things
that we see on TV and on social media
that we're supposed to want that we're
supposed to climb higher for and it was
just freeing to say I'm not gonna play
that game and I'm gonna look at the
resources that I've been blessed with
both you know the resources and the
talents maybe around promoting or
storytelling the money that I have and
and how can I use those to be a blessing
to others and I think you can start
small can start with 8 dollars and 15
cents they could start with a birthday
party where the first well was built and
you know for me I just wanted more and
more and more and the more I gave the
more I wanted to give you know I I love
that the more you give the more you give
and I would encourage people just to
step out and you know set the cynicism
aside to give your time and you're gonna
want to give more time you know maybe
it's a local charity maybe it's a
something in your neighborhood but dig
in you know give your money and and give
it to an organization where you actually
feel like you're gonna see the impact
and it's not just gonna go into a you
know into a black hole but I would hope
that that would feel good and you'd want
to do more of it and more of it
more of it and the next thing you know
you look back and you say wow I just was
preparing a doner report recently for a
family who'd been with us for eight
years and then we you know we said
here's your total eight years of giving
here's your impact all around the world
and they wrote back and they said we had
no idea was that much we had no idea we
had given over a half a million dollars
I think they felt like it was less than
half of that and that's the experience
right when you just they were just
showing up every year giving as they
could to giving some profits of their
business and then you know we're like
hey here's your summary you're like oh
my gosh it's kind of like screen time
just popped up yeah and I was like oh my
gosh I spent that much phone on my I
spent that much time on my iPhone Leslie
how's that possible so I would hope you
know in the positive as you give your
time as you give you talent as you give
your money in the service of others you
do get to look back and say wow that's
that's a significant impact
I really have transformed people's lives
and transform my own life in the process
well you have transformed my life and
it's been a blessing and an honor to be
able to contribute to your incredible
organization man and you inspire me in
more ways than you know so I thank you
for your service thanks for doing this
here today and I wanted to kind of end
this by saying that this podcast I
believe is going up on October 21 my
birthday is October 20th so happy
birthday because I am the bottleneck in
everything that I do and I've been
spread so thin I didn't have my act
together in time to launch a birthday
campaign well in advance of my birthday
so can I still launch a birthday
campaign for my birthday and leave it
open and throw perhaps the end of the
year or something like that all right so
when this goes up this will serve as the
official announcement that I am
dedicating my 52nd birthday to charity
water so I'll put up links and all the
information on how you can contribute to
that because I don't want anything for
my birthday other than for all of you to
experience what I've experienced and
what Scott is speaking about that
feeling that you get when you contribute
to the betterment of
I'll be your first donor yeah you got
152 busts for me right now and that's
the people thank you sir
back into your organization and of
course the spring if people want to
learn more about the spring and you can
go to charity water or gas or slash
personal there there you go I think that
link is still alive yes yeah so charity
water org slash rich roll I'll make sure
it's live before this goes up and
everybody pick up thirst available
everywhere you buy books it's a
fantastic read this is a huge
accomplishment super excited for you and
more will be revealed come back and talk
to me again well maybe we'll do one from
Ethiopia in March that would be cool
let's take a 30-minute pod round it to
the Bell opening okay thirty minutes
well like from a way we can interview
some local people about translators
let's do not actually they'd be amazing
I'd love to do that and we'll see and we
might even be able to get to one your
birthday well so okay well sorry I'm
gonna I'm gonna work on it alright
thanks Scott peace clean water
[Music]